Reviews have become a common part of everyday software development practice.
As such, much has been learned about how to perform them.
What follows in this lesson are some dos and don'ts of gleaned from
actual experience. We begin with some about the participants. First off,
reviews should not be used for personnel eva, evaluations.
If participants feel that what they say about someone else's code will affect
their performance rating or salary, they may be reluctant to speak. For
this reason managers should in general not attend review meetings unless they
have participated technically in the production of the artifact being reviewed.
Or they're outside of the participant's reporting hierarchy. Similarly,
in general it is not a good idea to allow non-participant observers in
review meetings as they can provide distractions. Don't treat a review as
an opportunity for training new staff members. This will reduce the productivity
of the review session. Instead, hold a separate meeting with the trainee.
The author of the artifact being reviewed should not be the moderator or
recording. These are specialized tasks that require full concentration.
Some organizations also require that the author not be the reader.